let's talk about the best herbs for parasites
now what is a parasite a parasite could be some
microorganism a worm a bacteria that basically
lives off your body but doesn't give you anything
back at least your friendly bacteria exchange with
you they give you immune protection they help make
vitamins vitamin k k2 a whole series of b vitamins
they actually make antioxidants they'll even eat
things that you don't even eat they'll eat
fiber and they convert it into things like
chemicals like butyrate which help give your colon
cells energy and they even help with your blood
sugars let me give you another example of what i
consider a parasite one day i saw this flyer of
this guy who's will come your house and cut your
grass call them up say he's going to cut my grass
so i left i had to go somewhere i come back he
broke into my house and he stole things and not
only that he didn't even cut my grass so that
would be an example of someone taking something
but not giving anything back all right so let's
talk about some of the symptoms that might occur
if someone has parasites all right number one
fatigue that's a real big symptom weight loss
itchy private parts bloating
your nauseous diarrhea
now what are the best remedies for parasites
wormwood extract you can get this at the health
of the store it's a very very toxic plant
for parasites because the goal is to make the
environment so unfriendly that the parasites have
to leave your body number two black walnut halls
very very toxic to parasites garlic has been
known to even kill parasites and clove okay this
is the combination that i would recommend now of
course when you are trying to get rid of parasites
you want to avoid certain foods especially sugary
foods refined carbohydrates and definitely milk
now before you start these herbs i'm going
to recommend you get some purified bile salts
and you want to take i'd say maybe three
through the day on an empty stomach
so maybe you take one in the morning one in the
early afternoon and then maybe one before you
go to bed okay so do that for one day then
the second day you start on this protocol
why because when you take purified bile salts you
will start to open up the flows of your bile ducts
and because when you start to take these herbs
it's going to kill off microbes it can even break
open the microbe which could actually release
endotoxins which tend to shut down the bile ducts
and that's when you feel sick when you're
trying to do a detox or you're trying to kill
off parasites or fungus so i always recommend this
take this one little step get your liver and bile
ducts flowing first for a day then do this i've
learned the hard way i've done so many different
cleanses and even parasite cleanses and i end
up getting sick because i didn't know about this
you keep those bile ducts open and keep things
flowing and you won't have any detox reactions so
when you take these as well go slow like maybe
take one of each see how you do and then the
next day take a little bit more a little bit
more until you reach the recommended amount
on the directions that is on the bottle now when
you're doing parasite cleanses i would do them for
minimally one month but maybe six weeks and
then at that point stop taking it see how you
do and it's not a bad thing to do this every
so often maybe every six months and one last
thing that i think is really really important
is taking apple cider vinegar on a regular basis
you can even give apple cider vinegar
to animals to kill off their parasites
so this is a really good thing for humans as
well all right thanks for watching hey before
you go real quick i have a course entitled how
to bulletproof your immune system it's a free
course i want you to take it and here's
why here's you here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding your environment but what about here
what about strengthening your immune system
that's what's missing this course will show
you how to bulletproof yourself and so you can
tolerate and resist your environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today